c'est demain que christine villemin sera
si les juges de la cour d'appel de nancy
vont la laisser sortir de prison
la chambre d'accusation répandra dans
l'après-midi à sa demande de mise en
liberté s'il allait sortir l'instruction
de cette affaire qui a connu bien des
rebondissements depuis huit mois
pourrait prendre une fois de plus un
tour nouveau
hélène risacher pour une demande de mise
en liberté les magistrats de la chambre
d'accusation ne statue habituellement
que sur la forme
aujourd'hui pour ce dossier exceptionnel
on a abordé aussi le fond l'audience
avec les avocats a duré cinq heures
pour la défense m au garrot plaide
l'absence de preuve m lombard pour la
famille partie civile demande la mise en
liberté de christine villemin
tout en restant neutre sur la question
de sa culpabilité
j'ai demandé qu'on applique les grands
principes qui sont comment pourrais je
dire la base du droit français
la chambre d'accusation est une
juridiction majeur rarement j'ai assisté
à une audience aussi prenante aussi
plein aussi émouvante
chacun avait conscience de l'immense
responsabilité qui portait en lui vous
savez vous trouverez peu d'avocats qui
soit contre la liberté car il ne faut
pas confondre liberté et que le baby
lité ces deux notions de cellules en
différentes
la chambre d'accusation rendra sa
décision demain à 16 heures l'enjeu de
cet arbitrage est important pour le juge
lambert chargés de la faire si christine
villemin est maintenu dans sa prison de
metz-queuleu le choix du juge est
confirmée dans le cas contraire mise en
liberté éventuellement sous contrôle
judiciaire le juge lambert pourrait se
sentir désavoué et demandé à être
dessaisi du dossier l'avocat m au garrot
et madame chatel blaise la mère de
christine villemin ont rendu visite en
fin d'après-midi à la jeune femme
inculpé de l'homicide volontaire de son
fils ce que la confiance en lui oui la
coupe ya arrêté par hasard ça n'avait
pas dans ce sens qu'elle souhaite elle
recommencera sa grève de la faim
oui oui on va sûrement lui si cette
année ainsi qu'un événement plus
confiant